peu
[Musique]
je
ans
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
on
ça commence comme queen normal et on a
vu le cap le caniveau déborder toute la
zone est inondée
toute la maison louée à arriver
jusqu'aux presque au plafond pouvais me
lui circuler dans le salon l'eau après
toutes les pièces complètes aux méchants
maintenant accès à ma chambre moi parce
que la version combi d'eric besson dans
le var c'est la cata la porte est cassé
et porte la surface et c'est vraiment
somptueux buffet sera servi va même pas
dormi
[Musique]
on n'avait que sa montée c'était beau
monde à mon avis deux sorties pour aller
là-bas c'est vraiment difficile de s'en
sortir donc on a lutté avec les
pavements loup dans le courant de goury
tout ça qu'on arrivait au fus rabat et à
notre tournée vous voulez manger une
commune concernant tout produit toutes
les machines
[Musique]
oh